first of all thank you so much for being
so nice to see you again and I heard
that I love the beard by the way it
looks you do yes salt and pepper salt
and pepper yeah that's how they call it
but I have to recognize that I dye it a
little bit you died oh yeah yeah and
just preparing a character that I want
man
for him to just wear beer and I'm just
trying to find him through the beer I'm
sure there'd be more salt yeah yeah now
I'm curious this is everything to do
with I heard that you're planning to
play Picasso we're hoping to play
Picasso somewhere that might be in the
works we to play Picasso yes
is that what well I think if you do that
would be amazing perfect part that we he
wouldn't have a beard no no I never wear
a B I know that this is for another
movie and when I start in a week from
now in Bulgaria Sofia we've been
Kingsley and it's an action movie and so
I thought that the character that I play
has something to hide so I just put a
mask on my face which is the big right
that would take me a year to grow what
you have right there I have you know
what happened this morning when I woke
up I look at myself and I look like an
evangelist I just I don't think it's
gonna work for the character anymore I
have to just get there I'm probably
gonna shave it yeah yeah so you think
this could be for nothing for nothing
this off yeah are you accept you you
have for a long time I brought up
Picasso because you've wanted to play
him for a long time you're very
passionate about it are you from the
same hometown same to home television
from mother the South in Spain Picasso
it was from Wow
same time as Picasso and and obviously
you're you're learning a lot about
Picasso is that right I am I am and
starting him and trying just to you know
portray him properly honestly and though
I knew because I've been them because
has been part of my life yes one of
those guys he left town actually
practically the same age that I left and
so he's being a early in my life
he's one of the biggest artists of the
20th century
I cannot imitate him but but he's there
and it's interesting character is very
fascinating he loved he loved women and
it was a big very much loved women big
part of his life very much and it got
complicated with Picasso right yeah
because he loved women it'll be too much
yeah
I don't think there's any such thing
actually and the side is it's a greedy
disagree no he actually he got a lot of
stories with women when he was still
married with olga akarova he established
a relationship with another woman
call maria theresa Walter and he was not
shy about it you know I mean he bought
an apartment right across the street
from the place for his mistress yeah
that's yours good all's on that guy
clearly I'm living here with my wife and
then a place for my mistress across the
street it must happen now yeah he was
not only unfaithful he was lazy have a
good thing the other side of town no
don't want to meet them no no no I'm not
gonna go looking at places right over
there there's a glass ha ha ha wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]